today yes we do spend money in getting
our children in admission in medical
college like in India and many parts of
the world if you don't get good marks
you can pay money and get admission
$100,000 you get admission £200,000
£100,000
£200,000 you get
admission but do spend this amount in
making your
child an Islamic
scholar who do that and here at that
time the mother
spends 30,000 dinar more than 2 million
pounds so that he gets the best Islamic
education of that time so if we know
what is the value of the knowledge of
dean then you realize it is
invaluable it's inval valuable. When we
read history, we come to know that from
the 8th to the 12th
century, it was known as the dark
ages. Dark ages for the
Europeans, not for the world. The amount
of
advances in science and technology the
Muslims did at that time, it was
phenomenal. But because the European
were not advanced, they call it the dark
ages. But the amount of
invention and advancement the Arabs and
the Muslim did between the 8th to the
12th century is phenomenal.
We
know when
we go to
school, we learn in school that the
blood circulation was first
propounded by William Harvey by William
Harvey. That's about a thousand years
before or about 800 years
before. But if you read history, we come
to know that
Nafi the Muslim scientist, he spoke
about birth
circulation 400 years before William
Havi and 600 years after the Quran was
revealed and he got the information from
the Quran. Allah says in the Quran in
surah Nahel chapter number 16 verse
number
66. Verily in the cattle is a lesson for
you. We give you to drink from what is
within the
body. Milk which is pure coming from
between the contents of the intestine
and excretor. Milk which is pure for you
to
drink. We know by science today that
what we eat goes into the stomach. from
the stomach via the bloodstream goes
into the various organs of the body the
nutrients including the mammorary glands
which responsible for the production of
milk. So this thing what science has
come to know today is already mentioned
in a nutshell in surah hell chapter 16
verse 66 400 years ago but in our text
books science
textbooks we learn about William Harvey
but we don't learn about
nafi the first human being he drew the
who drew the map of the world it was
aldrusi in 1100
184. And when the Muslim cgraphers drew
the world map, they drew the world map
with South Pole on top and north pole
down. And alhamdulillah, the Caba was in
the center. Later on, the western
ctographers come and they turn the map
upside down. North pole on top, South
Pole down. But yet, alhamdulillah, the
Cabba is in the center.
We
know that there are two types of
numerals. Roman numerals and the Arabic
numerals. Why is the Arabic numerous
called
Arabic? Because Roman, you know, it's in
lines 1 2 3
lines. The Indians they discovered the
zero. The Muslims they put a decimal
point and they introduced a new system
called as Arabic numerals. So what you
read 1 2 3 4 now it's actually called as
Arabic
numerals introduced by the Muslims.